to make ultra-thin glass manufacturers
use standard materials such as lime sand
soda and potash a worker measures the
secondary smaller ingredients manually
and adds them to the batch these
ingredients enhance qualities like
optical clarity or electrical
sensitivity the card transfers the batch
to a mixer as it blends everything
together they add bits of broken or
waste glass to it for recycling purposes
[Music]
once it's been thoroughly mixed a lift
raises a funnel-shaped container up to
the base of the mixer and the mixer
releases the batch into it
a worker hauls the batch Laden funnel
tank to the next station
there a crane takes over and lowers the
tank onto a feeder system just above a
gas and electric furnace a trapdoor
opens at the funnels base and the
mixture flows into the feeder mechanism
it's a kind of shovel that slowly pushes
the mixture into the furnace which has
been fired to a blazing 2732 degrees
Fahrenheit the shovel continuously adds
more ingredients to keep production
flowing glass production runs 24/7 the
melting glass reaches the consistency of
honey
the molten glass flows out through a
narrow slit and this slit establishes
the ultra-thin dimensions of the glass
cooling the glass slowly relieves
internal stresses as the glass
solidifies ultra-thin glass can be just
25 microns thick that's finer than a
hair and it's this thinness that makes
it so flexible the glass bends to loop
down and up across rollers as a journeys
forward in a continuous nearly two foot
wide sheet and unlike ordinary glass it
doesn't crack
it then travels past tiny cameras and
laser sensors that look for defects like
bubbles another lab worker places a
bigger segment of the glass under a
cutter he aligns it correctly and then
activates the cutter it scribes the
glass so it can be broken on this line
creating small screens for smartphones
and smartwatches
a lab technician examines the glass for
scratches under a bright light and
confirms that it's undamaged